[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today this is
the Ramsey show what's up
hey
um I just was calling because first of
all I wanted to tell you John that um I
have engaged in some pretty destructive
behaviors in our marriage um with money
and I could never figure out why I was
doing it until I started listening to
you and so my husband and I have been
able to kind of cut off with credit card
debt all of our cars are paid off we
don't have any other debt besides that
um I'm so proud
of you it's awesome
um but he has decided to sell his Jeep
that
um he loves to pay off this credit card
debt and I just feel really guilty
because I know most of it was me making
just really resentful and dumb choices
yeah
he loves that jeep
he does how much
I mean he's willing to get rid of it he
want he no no how much does he love that
cheap
um a lot I mean give me an example how
much
a lot a lot more than like kind of a
ridiculous amount kind of like almost
annoying how much he loves his Jeep
no no he's not like a jeeper like he
doesn't
here's what I'm getting at he loves you
more
don't take that from him
okay he signed up ride or die with
brandy
and he's he's known for a long time you
were hurting
and probably some of the fights y'all
had were very tactical things about
money and credit card debt and you have
done the hard work
to dig in beneath that why in the world
am I spending on this am I out of
control here why when I get nervous or
scared or when my mom calls I spin like
crate whatever you did that work
and then he exhaled and went oh thank
God now we got a plan I'm all in
okay and a giant giant Go-Kart with
humongous tires comes way after
the woman I love
okay
sounds good guilt is fine guilt is fair
that's cool
it becomes ugly when your guilt becomes
shame and you know the difference
um guilt is I did some stupid things
with money shame is I am stupid and I
always will be
okay it's okay to feel guilty you did
some did you do some dumb things with
money
yeah yeah that's cool that's just your
body doing what's supposed to do letting
you know let's don't do that again
remember how that felt that's cool
shame is I'm not going to be able to
breathe because as we're cleaning up
other people who love me so much have
agreed to participate in the cleanup
by the way he signed up for that when he
said I do it's part of it
okay cool um yeah I just was wondering
with it to like
um so we were two income we've gone down
to one income for me to go back to
school
um because we have three kids and anyway
um I just
I know that he would have sold this beep
anyway to make like to provide more for
them while we were on income so every
time things come up where it's like
we're canceling music lessons or
something for my kids I just like feel
so the greatest gift the greatest gift
you can give your kids is a well Mom
okay by a hundred miles
way more important than a violin lesson
or whatever is a mom who has peace
inside her chest
okay
so every time you go to counseling every
time you have to cancel something
because you're back in school every time
you are staying up late and you have to
miss a ball game because you have an
exam the next day
exhale and think
what a gift I'm giving my kids I'm
giving them a peaceful mom a well mother
I'm giving them warmth and laughter in
their home
because when I get out of school it's
going to be gangbusters
I can't believe I missed this t-ball
game
whatever I promise you of all the t-ball
games they have they're not gonna
remember the one you lost they don't
even remember what they ate for dinner
yesterday
they will remember
how mom made him feel
okay it was Mom safe was Mom anxious all
the time was Mom scared all the time or
was Mom
the the one warm place I always knew I
could go to
and that's the work you're doing right
now
all right is that fair
do you believe me
um you don't have to please my kids are
teenagers so I that makes it a little
different but I think it doesn't like
talking can I tell you one more
take each one of them out for breakfast
and tell them
age appropriate I would tell that
differently to my 13 year old than I
would an 18 year old
but Mom's going through a hard season
and you're watching your mom become a
gangster in front of your very eyes
and I'm gonna tell you I have a mom that
had a hard
some hard experiences went back to
school at 42 and you probably heard that
story I went back to school at 42 First
Community College class at 42 and then
she took another one the next year and
another one the next semester
and then she graduated with her PhD at
57.
then she got tenured as a professor at
63 and we all just celebrated her
because she finished her last year at
Oxford in her 70s
she had a whole gangster back half of
her life that started when I was a
teenager
and it was hard she missed games I had
to make dinner on my own sometimes and I
wouldn't trade any of it for the the
watching my mom take a machete and head
out into a field and carve a path and
watching my dad support her all the way
wouldn't trade a second of that
okay okay I've lived I've lived it
you're doing the right thing I'm proud
of you proud of you proud of you proud
of you proud of you it's awesome good
for you